there is one extremely important and  fundamental piece of advice that is  relevant when you write your cover  letters in your cvs when applying to  consulting industry or any other job for  that matter and this is the principle of  show don't tell don't just write things  like i'm a very good team player i'm a  very good communicator talk is cheap  everyone can just say that claim that  write that instead mention specific  examples of your life where you have  been a good team player where you have  been a good communicator and to what  results that led show them the instances  where you prove that you have these  skills don't just claim don't just tell  you have them so show don't tell follow  me for more career advice